and I am way smarter about my
relationships online now than I ever was
I'm so proud of myself Liz Topia is
about to have a Heyday with this but
I've I've had two talking to experiences
and normally the internet knows like
this you've had two what like talking
twos like like people that like like
talking to someone not fully in a
relationship like they're getting to
know each other okay and like normally
the internet in a day somehow figures it
out but I I it's in these last oh my God
eight months I've been able to keep it
private you've got you have secret
relationships now yeah or private
relations I think I think private's a
better word um because I'm not hiding it
it's more just like I don't want that
person's life whoever that other
significant other is to be fully on
display and like the reality is I'm 20.
anyone I date is going to be from 19 to
I mean I'm into older so like oh you are
what's this what's the oldest person
that you were uh interested in where do
you draw the line what is the okay where
I would draw the line would you go out
with a woman in Assisted Living
I mean that's the way she rolls it's not
okay it's not old so like don't think
that I'm calling anybody above this old
but like for me dating is like
19 but I would prefer like 22 I really
just like older than me but to like 28
. oh well because you feel like you're
Mormon ooh to make it more is that a
cougar I mean no it's I think because
I've only just been surrounded by people
older than my life you know I've dated a
little younger than me I've dared a
little older than me and there
definitely is some maturity disconnect
because you can't even go into a bar yet
that is true right so somebody 28 where
did they where do you where do you go
there's a lot of people
Dave and Busters
that your audience would know like that
they would no not so maybe that's why
they where where do you where do you
talk to these people do people slide
into DMS yes people slide into the DMS
now and I was I never understood sliding
into the DMs I was like nobody says in
my DMs then I open my DMs I was like oh
people do how did you how did you get on
this show today
because you slid into my ideas don't be
creepy Dad here I am and I'm and I'm 67.
what did you say to me that you're going
to like what jump into the DM you didn't
even know sliding I didn't know I didn't
slide it at my age I don't slide like
I'm gonna walk I'm gonna slow I'm just
gonna creep into her DMV and I said
please be on my podcast it was great I
was very grateful that you did yeah and
you right away boom she was there this
is like yeah we have JoJo seesaw here
this literally was like three days ago
yeah
but now when people listen to this your
your DMs are just gonna blow up now wide
open and they're willing to talk to you
people and if you're 29 don't do it
twenty 19 to 28 slide in I'm five I'm 29
too oh yeah it's fine you're not in an
exclusive relationship right right now
no no no no I haven't I haven't been in
a true relationship since
oh
December November December
okay so it's it's been a minute I've
been single for for quite some time and
it's
been nice I uh do you are you concerned
when uh
people
want to meet you and talk to you and
maybe engage in you do you think you've
got good radar as far as it's not JoJo
siwa you know you're a brand as you you
refer to yourself as a brand yeah and
you know that that is enticing to many
many people and I have I've had that
happen a lot and it's
how do you how do you discover that so
it's right away I know how do you know
right away because I can tell I've only
had a very very few amount of people
that are not interested in JoJo C with a
brand
I don't care about what you do I like
you it's interesting it's it's kind of
just like a feeling and it's like if
somebody asks me something say they're
like what do you do for fun and I'm like
oh you know my favorite thing to do is
like perform they'll be like no that's
like Jojo Jojo what do you what do you
like to do for fun and I'll be like oh I
like to indoor skydive you know what I
mean and so
I can tell when someone's more
interested in one thing but I can also
tell when someone doesn't respect my
career either and they just like fully
throw it away so it's got to be this
fine balance but because there's only
been a very small amount of people that
I can fully let my guard down I can
almost tell instantly when there's
somebody that I can and
I've learned in the in the dating world
that I
either have to immediately accept and
just be a kid and have fun like I don't
need to date that serious I'm 20.
and accept that like you know they might
they might be in here for wrong
intentions or I have to be like okay
they're here for wrong intentions let's
not do this
[Music]